>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Good
evening ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the Library of
congress, my name is Nicholas Brown
and I'm a music specialist here
in the music division and one
of the producers of the
Library's concert series.
We're so pleased to have you
here tonight for a lecture
by Jean Snyder on Harry T. Burleigh.
And Jean of course has recently
published a book on Mr. Burleigh
and will be getting into all
kinds of wonderful information
about his music and his impact which
has been immense on American music.
Just a bit about this evening
and our concert series,
the lecture will be about an
hour, there will be a Q & A period
for the Q & A we ask that you wait
for a microphone to be brought
after you've raised your hand
because we are filming the event
for our digital collections,
the video will go
out on the libraries
website, loc.gov.
And also on our YouTube channel,
youtube.com/library of congress.
Feel free to subscribe to
video and email alerts on any
of those platforms to get all kinds
of wonderful content from events
that perhaps you aren't
able to attend.
Following the conclusion of the
talk there will be an opportunity
to purchase copies of Jean's
book which are available
over there courtesy of the Libraries
shop they are at a discounted price
of $28, which is really exciting
so thank the library for that.
And Jean will be signing
books at the table just
over there at the conclusion.
This event is being
presented as part
of the libraries African-American
history month celebrations.
You can visit our online portal
for African-American history month
which is
africanamericanhistorymonth.gov.
It is a partnership between the
Library of Congress, the Smithsonian
and the National Archives
as well as other entities
within the federal government.
And just a word about our
collections and Harry T. Burleigh
in the collections, we have
a huge amount of his music,
a lot of it came to us
through a copy write deposit
and if you visit our website loc.gov
in the top search box
you can type in his name.
And you will get all kinds
of wonderful resources.
Some of those resources are under
copy write so you might only be able
to pull them up in full
high resolution onsite here
at the library but
definitely check those out,
there's some great resources and a
lot of wonderful articles written
in conjunction with some of
the sheet music on there.
And if you are working
with our collections
at a distance you can contact the
reference librarians any time,
loc.gov and then in the top
menu click down on the menu
and you'll get an Ask
a Librarian option.
So if you need to for example get
a scan of something for a paper
or you want a frame, a picture of
Mr. Burleigh you are totally welcome
to connect with our
staff to figure that out.
A couple of other exciting
events coming up,
we have one of our Library of
Congress jazz scholars appearing
for the first time this season
on March 1, that is Ingrid Monson
who is a distinguished jazz scholar
and is an acting Dean
up at Harvard right now.
And then coming up later in
the spring we have a bunch
of wonderful other string
quartet performances,
jazz saxophonist Steve Coleman has
been commissioned by the library
and we'll be premiering a
new piece of his in April.
And then Ambrose Akinmusire who
is a wonderful trumpeter will be
performing in May on the
20 and he is a recipient
of the Thelonious Monk award
and prize which is a big deal.
So he's going to be
really great to hear.
And stay tuned to our websites
for some really cool event
announcements coming up.
The two places to check
are loc.gov/concerts,
you can also visit
our Facebook page,
Library of Congress performing arts.
If you just type in Library of
Congress you'll find us on there.
All of our programs are free
and they are made possible
by private contributions
to the Library.
So if you're interested in
learning more about our friends
of music program you can
visit our website again
or visit loc.gov/philanthropy
to learn more
about making tax deductible
contributions.
Because without you there
would be none of these types
of programming here, so we
appreciate your investment
in the community in making
these events possible.
Without further ado we'll
welcome up Dr. Snyder
and she'll introduce herself.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Thank you
very much, Nick, he's been great
to work with in planning this event.
Good evening, I'm honored
to be here with you,
to tell the story of
Harry T. Burleigh.
Distinguished baritone, art
song composer, music editor
and pioneer arranger of spirituals.
I'm especially grateful to have
been invited to speak at the Library
of congress where I spent many hours
on numerous occasions
exploring the treasury
of the music divisions resources
of sheet music, music journals,
recordings, collections of
personal papers, of composers.
And being guided by the wisdom
of librarians like the legendary
but now retired, Wayne Shirley.
Libraries are my favorite places
and this library is the best of all.
Now before I go further I need
to introduce a couple
of very special guests.
Burleigh's great grandson, Harry
T. Burleigh, III is with us.
[ Applause ]
and let me also introduce
Dewan Reese who is the Music
and Performing Arts curator
at the new Smithsonian Museum
of African-American
history and culture.
[ Applause ]
And Harry's sister Marie is on
her way but stuck in traffic
so when she comes I'll be
sure to acknowledge her too.
Exactly 100 years ago
in the 1916-1917 concert season
Harry T. Burleigh's art song
arrangements of spirituals
literally hit the charts.
Critics in New York and Boston
reported that Burleigh's arrangement
of Deep River was the
song most often performed
in recitals that season.
In addition, to advertisements by
his publisher in a musical America
that listed singers
who were performing it.
The cover of one 1917 edition
of Deep River featured the names
of 21 famous singers
who were singing it.
President Woodrow Wilson's
daughter Margaret sang it,
composer Dudley Buck's
voice student sang it,
African-American tenors Roland
Hayes and Sidney Woodward sang it.
Deep River was one of 14 Burleigh
spiritual arrangements published
that season bringing the
powerful songs created
by African-Americans during the dark
days of slavery to the concert stage
and to choir lofts
around the country
and far beyond our American shores.
Today 100 years later we are still
singing Harry T. Burleigh's solo
and choral arrangements
of spirituals.
You can check them on YouTube
and you can also check his
ever expanding discography,
you'll find one on my
website, harrytburleigh.com.
Who was Harry T. Burleigh and
why are the spirituals important.
First of all as I'm sure you know,
Harry T. Burleigh was born
150 years ago in Erie,
Pennsylvania on December 2, 1866.
We've just been celebrating
his sesquicentennial.
He was a third generation free man
whose grandfather had been a slave
in Summerset County, Maryland.
And with his grandfather, Hamilton
Waters, begins what we know
of the story of Harry T. Burleigh.
It is a quintessential American
story one that can tell us
and our children more about
who we are and who we can be.
What was it that prepared
Harry T. Burleigh to move
with such distinction,
first as a baritone soloist
in his home town much in demand.
Then at age 25 to study at the
National Conservatory of Music
in New York City and as a singer
throughout the eastern seaboard
and as far west as Minneapolis.
Then nationally and internationally
as a composer of art songs.
Songs written for a trained
singer, secular songs,
usually accompanied by piano.
As a highly respected music
editor at the New York office
of the Recording Music Company and
finally as a pioneering arranger
and singer of and esteemed
lecturer on the spirituals.
A vast repertoire of music
that has generated many
of Americas most vibrant
music traditions.
What was it that equipped Burleigh
to move far beyond his
African-American community in Erie.
First of all there was no
question that it was his family
who had nurtured him, who supported
him in moving toward the fulfillment
of his impossible dreams.
Who demonstrated a
determined love for education
and a staunch moral integrity
as well as a love for music.
They endowed him by inheritance
with rare musical gifts,
more specifically his
grandfather Hamilton Waters
who purchased his freedom for $50
and his mother's freedom
for $5 in 1832.
His mother, Elizabeth Waters
Burleigh Elmendorf who graduated
from Avery college in
Pittsburgh in 1855.
Burleigh credited her with keeping
him focused on his highest goals.
His Aunt Louisa Waters who paid
for his first piano lessons
and in whom he confided when as
a teenager his suffered taunts
and bullying from his classmates.
His father, Henry Thacker
Burleigh, a union Navy veteran
who in 1871 was the first
African-American to serve
on a jury in Erie County.
His step-father John Edgar Elmendorf
also a veteran of the Union Navy
who modeled for him and active
involvement in public life.
Including directly challenging
the republican establishment
that betrayed it's
promises to the man
who had delivered Erie's black
vote in the election of 1888.
Burleigh's grandfather,
Hamilton Waters was said
to have an exceptionally melodious
voice and here you see him
with two year old Harry
and 4 year old Reginald.
This is about 1869.
He shared with Harry and his brother
Reginald the precious heritage
of the songs and storied
created by the slaves.
In later years Burleigh often
referred to his grandfather
and as his father died when he
was only 6 years old it is likely
that his grandfather
and his step-father
influenced him more profoundly.
Much more could be said about
Burleigh's family but let's move
to the musical soundscape that
shaped Burleigh's early life.
He commented that the first music he
ever heard was the rumble of trains
and the songs of stevedores.
It was a short walk from his
home on 3rd street to the docks
at the north end of state
street and the train tracks
that ran along the bay front.
Long before Burleigh worked as a
pantry man on the lake steamers,
he heard the singing of
dock workers and stevedores,
many of whom were from the south.
Did he hear jubilees or spirituals
on the docks as well as well
as from his grandfather
and his mother?
Perhaps this is where he first
heard the roust about sound, Oh,
Rock Me Julie, which he
arranged for publication in 1914.
Burleigh said I don't recall
when I first started singing,
it seems I've been
doing so since infancy.
The whole family was very musical
and they often had family
concerts in their home.
The first newspaper accounts
of Burleigh singing were
as part of a family quartet.
He described his mother as a
natural singer and credited her
as his first music teacher.
He learned spirituals from her
as well as from his grandfather.
In his mother Burleigh saw a
love for art music combined
with an appreciation of
black music at a time
when many educated
African-Americans wanted
to forget those reminders
of slavery.
Burleigh's life-long commitment to
church music and to an episcopal
of mode of worship was nurtured at
the episcopal cathedral of St. Paul
where he and his family were taken
in as members just a few
years after the Civil War.
Burleigh attended St. Paul's on
Sunday mornings with his mother.
The congregation was
known for its fine singing
and he was a charter member of
the St. Paul men and boys' choir,
you see him in the
third row at the right
and you'll also see two young
soprano's African-Americans,
Charles Fisher and Charles Franklin.
The congregation was known for
its fine singing, I said that.
A survey of the hymns, anthems
and liturgical responses chosen
by the organist and choir director
with whom Burleigh sang shows
that his years at St. Paul's
introduced him to composers
of church music such as
Palestrina, Tallis, Hydn, Beethoven,
Voreth, Stainer and many others.
Given the importance of
Burleigh's role in preserving
and promoting the spirituals,
it is important to know when
and where he heard
and sang them in Erie.
Erie's newspapers seldom recorded
performances of spirituals
by black citizens,
though this main mean
that they rarely sang
them publicly rather
than they didn't sing them at all.
The St. James A.M.E. church
was established in 1874
and though Burleigh and his mother
attended St. Paul's the families
social life centered at St. James.
The early leaders of the
African, Methodist, Episcopal
or A.M.E. church wanted their
members to demonstrate their ability
to move into more enlightened
American culture.
And they did not encourage the use
of the songs, the cornfield ditties,
as Bishop Payne called them.
Created by their unschooled
ancestors.
However the folks of St. James
did sing spirituals occasionally
at fund raising events.
Burleigh's grandfather
was a lifelong member
of the Himrod Mission which offered
instruction in reading, writing
and arithmetic as well
as Bible instruction.
One place we know Burleigh sang
spirituals was in the choir
at the Himrod Mission where
he led his blind grandfather
on Sunday afternoons.
Burleigh would have heard several
of the groups of Jubilee singers
that proliferated from
the 1870's on.
The success in the early 1870's
of the Fisk jubilee singers
in raising money for their Nashville
School inspired many imitators
who raised money for their
black schools in the south.
Jubilee performances were announced
in the Erie newspapers along
with vaudeville, minstrel,
popular theater
and opera troops coming to town.
Black performers were not
allowed to stay in local hotels
so black families provided
hospitality.
And it was common for travelling
musicians to perform at a reception
or gathering after the concert.
Burleigh would have heard
and no doubt met some
of the finest black singers
of his time before he
left for New York City.
When the New Orleans University
jubilee singers came to Erie
in May 1888 Burleigh
joined the troop.
Travelling with them until they
returned to Erie in December.
So Burleigh was familiar with
the diverse repertoire presented
by the touring jubilee singers.
Jubilee songs, sacred songs,
secular plantation songs,
alongside ballads and power songs.
Burleigh's fine voice was
discovered in elementary school
and in his late teens while
he was attending high school.
While he was also taking business
courses at Clark's Business College,
he was increasingly in demand
for solos and ensembles
at church and community events.
We know Burleigh as a singer but he
gained proficiency on the guitar,
the violin, the bass violin
and the timpani as well.
A survey of the Erie
Morning Dispatch
and the Cleveland Gazette a
black newspaper founded in 1883,
shows that by the time Burleigh left
Erie in 1892 he was considered one
of the finest classical
singers in the city.
In addition to singing in
the men and boys' choir
at St. Paul's he was a paid
soloist at Park Presbyterian church,
First Presbyterian church
and the Hebrew Synagogue.
By 1890 his solo repertoire had
become quite sophisticated including
opera arias in addition to German
leader and ballads and art songs
by European and American composers.
In September 1891 Burleigh again
left Erie to join a jubilee troop.
Frederick Louden from
Ravenna, Ohio was now manager
of the Fisk Jubilee singers.
Who had just returned from
a six year tour abroad.
Louden recruited Burleigh
who stopped
in Cleveland to visit friends.
But Burleigh's Erie fans
didn't want to let him go.
The Pastor and congregation
at the first Presbyterian Church
sent a telegram urging him
to decline the flattering
offer to join the Fisk tour.
They made their plea
irresistible by raising his salary.
Burleigh aborted his trip to
Ravenna and returned to Erie
but only a few months later
the opportunity to audition
at the National Conservatory
of Music
in New York City proved even
more compelling and now offer
from Erie Presbyterian's
could hold him back.
The National Conservatory
of Music was founded
by the indomitable Jeanette Therber
and she needs her own biography.
Trained at the Paris Conservatory
where talented French musicians
received the best music education
regardless of their ability to pay.
Therber believed young
American musicians deserved the
same opportunity.
American singers and composers
should not have to travel
to Europe to learn their craft.
They should receive the best
possible music education here
where they could find their own
distinctively American voices.
Burleigh was one of 200 applicants
for four tuition scholarships
for the artists course
at the conservatory.
Which would prepare them for
professional performing careers
and he was awarded one
of the four scholarships.
Burleigh quickly took
his place as one
of the best students
at the conservatory.
His music history teacher,
Henry Theophilus Finck,
music editor of the
New York Evening Post,
reported that Burleigh
was the best student
in music history he ever had.
He had trained as a stenographer
at the Clark Business College
and he copied his lectures
down verbatim in shorthand.
Therber had gathered
a stellar faculty
and Burleigh's accomplishments
as a student paved the way
for many opportunities
throughout his career.
For example his counter
point teacher,
Max Spicher [phonetic] was
instrumental in his being hired
in 1900 at the wealthy Temple
Emanuel where he sang for 25 years.
Even faculty members who
didn't actually teach Burleigh,
such as organ teacher Horatio Parker
remined his friends and supporters.
Burleigh didn't study
cello with Victor Herbert
but in 1914 Herbert invited him
to be one of the founding members
of ASCAP, the American Society of
Composers, Authors and Publishers.
But of course the most consequential
connection Burleigh made
at the conservatory was with
Czech composer Antonin Dvorak.
Who arrived in late
September to be the director
as Burleigh was beginning his
second semester at the conservatory.
Two faculty members
published the erroneous report
that Burleigh studied
composition with Dvorak.
As Burleigh later explained he
was not advanced enough to be
in Dvorak's composition class.
But when Dvorak heard him sing
he invited Burleigh to come
to the apartment where
he and his family lived
to sing the plantation songs
and spirituals he'd learned
from his grandfather.
Burleigh would sit down
at the Steinway piano,
loaned by William Steinway
whose store was nearby.
And accompanying himself would
sing the songs of the slaves.
The music in which the
composer was keenly interested.
Dvorak listened intently
and when struck
by a distinctive note he would jump
up and stop Burleigh to demand is
that really the way
the slaves sang it?
But Dvorak was interested not only
in the distinctive characteristics
of the music, Burleigh said
he asked hundreds of questions
about the lives of the
slaves that created it.
He urged Burleigh to give
those melodies to the world
and this mandate would
eventually become a primary mission
for Burleigh.
Burleigh was a music librarian
of the conservatory
orchestra, directed by Dvorak.
And he often accompanied
the composer on his jaunts
through the city and to the
shipyards and the railway yards
which Dvorak loved to visit.
Beautiful penmanship was
stressed in his business training
and Burleigh's superb
manuscript writing made him an
invaluable assistant.
He helped to copy the
orchestral parts for the premier
of the New World Symphony performed
in manuscript before
it was published.
And this is an example of his
manuscript writing, this is a song
that was dedicated to
Sophie Braslau, here she is.
I found that at the
Boston Public Library.
Dvorak believed in the
intrinsic value of the music
of ordinary Czech people.
He had used traditional
Bohemian songs
and dances in his compositions.
Now Dvorak was to fulfill
Jeanette Therber's intention
that the conservatory would help
American musicians find their
American voice.
As John c. Tibbets observed in his
1998 essay the missing title page,
Dvorak and the American National
Song and this is a long quote.
Quote, Dvorak's American
adventure was fraught
with significant and controversy.
The most modest of mean
he was himself a preacher
of contradictions.
Born a Czech villager,
a minority figure
in a German dominated
musical establishment.
Dvorak became a cosmopolitan artist
fettered in all the musical capitals
of Europe, Russia and America.
Many of his countrymen accused him
of turning his back
on his own roots.
And conversely the German musical
establishment criticized him
for his inordinate employment
of folk idioms in his music.
The truth is he lived in both
worlds exploiting the idioms
of his own culture in a
vocabulary befitting the academic
or classical style.
He was precisely the right
person to assume the leadership
of the national conservatory,
end of quote.
And we might add the precisely the
right mentor for Harry T. Burleigh.
Dvorak modeled a way
to live in two worlds.
How to succeed in the world
of western European influenced art
music while introducing his own
African derived music
heritage into that world.
In W.E.B. Du Boas' memorable phrase,
Burleigh would ever feel
his tunis [phonetic].
Even though in much of
his career he worked
within the white music
establishment,
Burleigh's goal was always to be a
worthy representative of his race.
Dvorak made music history
in May 1893 just
after he had finished composing
this New World Symphony.
By telling an interviewer
that he found in the music
of African-Americans
quote, all that is needed
for an American school
of music, end quote.
As you can imagine Burleigh's
comments were extremely
controversial, but for Burleigh
and other African-American musicians
his words were electrifying.
In August 1894 several months
after he had been hired
as baritone soloist at St.
George's Episcopal church
on Stuveysant Square where he
sang from more than 50 years.
Burleigh and Paul Bolin another
African-American student were
appointed to teach a new
cohort of black students
who were admitted to
the conservatory.
Burleigh taught voice and
soul-phage [phonetic].
By this time as the Chicago Observer
reported Burleigh was well-known
in the best sets read, elite
black communities of New York city
and Brooklyn as well as
Philadelphia, Washington
and other eastern cities.
He was becoming known
not only for his singing
but also for his compositions.
Burleigh's first published
composition was a simple Christmas
song for junior choir published
in 1896 by St. George's.
In 1898 his first set
of three art songs
and so began Burleigh's
little known,
but significant contribution
to American music.
His first art songs we're
published by G. Shirmer
but in 1902 William Maxwell became
Burleigh's primary publisher.
By 1903 when German contralto
Earnestine Schumann Heink made
Mammy's Lil' Baby part
of her repertoire,
more singers were singing and
recording Burleigh's songs.
And I wanted you to see this cover
because Louise Alston Burleigh
who wrote the lyrics
was Burleigh's wife.
I'd like you to hear Tenor Richard
Crooks sing Burleigh's 1904 setting
of the wedding song, O Perfect Love.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
From 1912 when William Maxwell's
brother George became the New York
representative of G. Ricordi
and Company based Milan,
Italy Recording became
Burleigh's publisher.
George Maxwell also hired
Burleigh as a music editor,
this securing him extraordinary
access to publication of his music.
For years Burleigh's songs
made up a significant section
of the Ricordi vocal catalogue.
He also facilitated publication
of music by other black composers.
Jester Harrison told me that he
and other younger composers
would bring their music
to the Ricordi office for
Burleigh's suggestions.
Harrison said he always
had time for us.
One of the strongest supporters
of Burleigh's work was A. Walter
Kramer, the music reviewer
of the Journal Musical America.
Kramer wrote overwhelmingly
positive reviews of Burleigh's songs
but he proclaimed that gospel of
high culture, calling Burleigh
to ascend it's heights by
writing serious art songs rather
than waste his talent in
writing the love ballads
that singers often used as encores.
Burleigh continued to write some
lighter ballad style songs but many
of his later songs reflected his
conscious movement from ballads
to the more serious art songs.
In 1914 Burleigh's first song
cycle, Saracen songs was published.
This was an example
of Burleigh's interest
in what was called orientalism.
A set of 7 songs with lyrics set
in the middle eastern desert.
The following year Ricordi
published five songs
by Lawrence Hope and Passionale.
The Lawrence Hope songs were
Burleigh's last orientalist pieces.
You see the requisite Lotus Blooms
and the Sari like, that's s-a-r-I,
dress of the young woman.
Lawrence Hope was the pin name
of Adela Florence Nicholson
who had grown up in India.
These are considered to be among
the best of Burleigh's art songs
and like many of his songs they
are written for lyric tenor.
John McCormick performed at least 26
of Burleigh's art songs including
the five songs of Lawrence Hope.
He often premiered them and he
recorded at least four of them.
He also sang at least four of
the spiritual arrangements.
When McCormick premiered
the Lawrence Hope songs
for an overflow audience that
included 600 people seated
on the stage, he had to repeat
the last song, Till I Wake.
One reviewer called this the
worthiest of the five songs.
Let's hear tenor Roderick
George sing, Till I Wake.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
Burleigh's third song cycle,
Passionale featured four poems
by Burleigh's friend
James Weldon Johnson,
each of these songs
was dedicated to one
of four tenors whom Burleigh knew
could sing them, John McCormick,
Evan Williams, Ben
Davies and George Hamlin.
In June 1915 musical America band
featuring a column entitled some
compositions by Americans who
are worthy of recognition.
The first list included
Burleigh's 19o03 song,
Jean and the Saracen songs.
Following issues listed Ethiopia
Saluting the Colors, He Sent Me You,
Just You and the Glory of
the Day was in Her Face,
the last of the Passionale songs.
In October 1915 Musical America
featured 27 noted concert artists
who listed their 10
favorite American songs.
Six of these singers listed songs
by Burleigh, of the other 21 singers
at least 10 performed
Burleigh's songs at various times.
When Zabetta Brenska, a
contralto who often performed
with her husband, tenor
Paul Althouse was asked
to name her favorite American
song, she found it difficult
to choose only one, but she said
if I had to narrow my choice
down to one composer I should
select Harry Burleigh's songs.
Most of Burleigh's more than 100 art
songs did not announce his identity
as an African-American though
some were setting of verse
by African-American poets.
They were songs about love,
beauty, nature, universal themes
that have occupied poets
and composers for centuries.
But Burleigh's penultimate published
art song is definitely a black
pride song.
His setting of the Langston Hughes
poem, Lovely Dark and Lonely one.
I've given you the
lyrics on your handout.
Burleigh wrote it with Marianne
Anderson's voice in mind,
but I don't know that she
ever performed it publicly.
Anderson's approach to the
racial divide was to bridge it
through her own very
personal dignity and grace.
But I believe it is
a fitting combination
of Burleigh's art song catalogue.
Along with his setting
of the John Oxenham hymn,
In Christ there is no East or West,
based on a spiritual the
angels changed my name.
Samual Clorage Taylor
had arranged this song
for his 1905 piano
collection, 24 Negro Melodies.
The hymn, In Christ there is no East
of West affirms Burleigh's
life-long hope
that through their art
African-American would help
to heal America's deepest wounds.
We need that healing
now more than ever.
I've given you the lyrics to
both of these songs but what
of the spiritual arrangements?
As early as 1901 Burleigh
was recognized as a promoter
of the intrinsic, artistic worth of
African-American traditional music.
In his recitals he always
performed at least one set
of songs reflecting
this music heritage.
And as early as 1903 his own
arrangements of spirituals.
This was more than a decade before
he began to publish the solo
and choral arrangements for
which we now know him today.
I've given you a copy
of a recital program
from 1908 that illustrates this.
In 1901 the Chap Book, everybody's
magazine published three Burleigh's
settings of plantation verse
written by Maria Howard Weeden.
She published it under
the name Howard Weeden.
The editor's note accompanying each
song shows that as early as 1901,
nine years after he
arrived in New York city,
Burleigh was championing
the artistic value
of African-American music.
This is a quote, Mr. Burleigh
well known as a baritone
at St. George's church New York and
as a composer has long been working
to show that the true Negro music is
really worthy of serious attention.
And is by no means
adequately represented
by the cheap Koontz
[phonetic] songs that have
so much vogue, end of quote.
From 1900 to 1915 Burleigh often
accompanied Booker T. Washington
on his tours through New
England raising money
for Tuskegee Institute.
Burleigh's singing opened the
purse strings of wealthy donors.
It was in these appearances
that Burleigh developed his
arrangements of spirituals.
Wouldn't it be wonderful
to have video recordings
of these improvisatory performances.
So we could study the development of
his style of arranging spirituals.
Burleigh's reputation of one
of the best American composers
of art songs prepared for
the immediate reception
of the spiritual arrangements
that were published
in the 1916, 1917 concert season.
Many of the performers who were
singing his art songs now greeted
his spiritual arrangements
with delight.
Two singes played a significant role
in bringing Burleigh's spiritual
arrangements to the floor.
The contralto soloist at
Temple Emanuel was Mary Jordan,
a renowned recitalist and opera
singer who performed a number
of Burleigh's art songs several
of which he dedicated to her.
Burleigh dedicated his
arrangement of Deep River to Jordan
and she sang and recorded it.
Baritone Oscar Seagle, the son of
a minster in Tennessee who had gone
to the camp meetings
with his father,
had searched for appropriate
arrangements
of the songs he had learned to love.
When he found Burleigh's
arrangements he immediately made
them an important part
of his repertoire.
In May 1917 Seagle ended a
recital in Brooklyn with a group
of Burleigh's spiritual
arrangements.
Burleigh said he sang like
a black preacher preaches.
And other singers followed Seagle's
example by ending their programs
with a group of spirituals.
Now Burleigh's solo
appearances shifted
to lecture recitals
on the spirituals.
And in the late 1920's
as radio waves began
to cover the country Burleigh's
voice was heard from the east
to the Midwest and as
far south as Texas.
Singing spirituals and speaking
about their history and importance
to American history, we need
a doctoral dissertation to see
when recordings first started to
be made of those radio programs.
Let's listen to a high school choir,
the Central Islip concert choir
from New York State, singing
Burleigh's choral arrangement
from arrangement of,
My Lord What a Morning.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
You notice that is not --
there is no accompaniment.
Burleigh's choral arrangements were
mostly meant to be sung acapella
and they're not easy, so this
is a really wonderful choir.
The St. George's annual vesper
service of Negro spirituals
which began in 1924
drew overflow crowds,
sometimes the police needed to help.
The newspaper announced
them ahead of time
and carried extensive
reviews afterward.
This is the program
for the first of them,
it was Burleigh's 30th
anniversary at St. George's
and they featured Burleigh as he
appeared in 1894 and his 1924 photo.
The programs always featured choral
and solo arrangements by Burleigh
and came to include other
arrangements by other composers
such as Hall Johnson,
Nathanial Dett, Eva Jesse,
John Work and Florence Price.
These annual service
continued until 1955,
six years after Burleigh
died in 1949.
It is impossible to overestimate
the importance of the emergence
of Burleigh's art song spiritual
arrangements 100 years ago.
Other composers black and
white immediately followed
with their own arrangements and by
1925 James Weldon Johnson commented
that the spirituals had a vogue.
At first Burleigh's arrangements
were used more extensively by white
than by black singers but
the enthusiastic reception
of his arrangements was noted
within the black community.
The 1917 Spingarn Award
acknowledged his contribution
in bringing the spirituals
to the attention
of the distinguished audiences
nationwide and in Europe.
The honorary master of arts degree
from Atlanta University in 1918
and the honorary Doctor
of Music degree
from Howard University in 1920.
Also recognized his role in helping
African-Americans reclaim spirituals
as an artistic heritage, rescuing
them from their association
with minstrelsy and vaudeville.
And making them accessible
to singers, and music lovers
of every cultural background.
And that was very important
to Burleigh.
In his prefaces to the two books of
American Negro spirituals published
in 1925 and 1926, James Walden
Johnson went so far as to say
that Burleigh's work had
been the principle factor
in reclaiming the spiritual
as a universally valuable
artistic expression.
This process had helped
African-American artists develop a
black esthetic.
The emergence of these artists
and I quote, zealous to be racial
or to put it better, to
be true to themselves,
to look for their artistic material
within rather than with out.
Got its first impulse
from the new evaluation
of the spiritual reached
by the Negro himself.
Almost suddenly the
realization broke upon the Negro
that in the spirituals the race had
produced one of the finest examples
of folk art in the world.
The result was a leaping pride,
coupled with the consciousness
of innate racial talents and powers
that gave rise to a new school
of Negro artists, end of quote.
The new vogue that the
spirituals enjoyed crowned
in Johnson's words a long
and steady development
in the recognition of their worth.
This swelling interest and pride in
the spirituals released new levels
of creativity among black
artists in the movement now known
as the Harlem Renaissance.
Or as some of its leaders
preferred to call it.
The New Negro Renaissance, that
extended far beyond Harlem.
At the end of his life
Burleigh expressed regret
that his many art songs
had fallen out of use.
But he took satisfaction in
the continuing popularity
of his spiritual arrangements.
He had helped to ensure that what
he called this great free fountain
of pure melody would
continue to flow.
That the spirituals with their
message of hope for freedom
and human family hood
would continue to be sung.
His work had helped in
the image he often used
to unlock the musical
treasure of the spiritual.
He had helped to coin that
treasure in universal currency.
He had as Antonin Dvorak
urged helped
to give those melodies
to the world, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Do you have questions or comments?
[ Background noise ]
>> Just wondering if there are any
extent recordings of him singing?
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: That's
a good question, Dr. Burleigh,
Harry T. Burleigh, II would always
tell people that there wasn't one
but when I asked him I think
he knew that I knew and he sort
of took a deep breath and said well,
there was one but he didn't like it.
It was recorded in 1919, this is
very early in recording technology.
Now as long as Dr. Burleigh was
alive I referred people to him.
He's no longer with us but someone
has posted that recording on YouTube
and the problem for me is
that I don't think Burleigh
sounded to his audiences.
I think the technology was
intimidating and I don't think --
he sounds stilted in that recording
and I don't think that's the
way he sounded to his audiences.
The reviews are glowing in
describing his engaging performance.
So, unfortunately he would never
agree to another recording,
he did accompany Edward
Boltner on another recording
and these were made by the George
W. Broom recording company.
And Broom was one of
Burleigh's friends,
this was the earliest
black recording company.
There were recordings made at
the 50th anniversary in 1946
but obviously Burleigh's voice was
long past his prime by that time
and those recordings were not made
public, they were made available
to people at St. George's, people
who sang with him in the choir.
I haven't seen those
but unfortunately we don't have a
recording of how he really sounded.
>> [inaudible] history of it
[inaudible] since Burleigh's time
and enter to the modern world.
Because I know we've gone through
periods of people you know,
making it more white in terms of
pronunciation of the language.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Are you
talking about the use of dialect?
>> Yes, dialect.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Yes, okay.
Burleigh commented that the
dialect softened the harshness
of the Anglo-Saxon language.
Some of his spiritual
arrangements are written
in what we call standard
English, some of them use dialect.
He didn't think -- he acknowledged
that the dialect had been
caricatured but he didn't think
that was a reason not to use it.
He was always concerned
that spirituals be
performed with dignity.
And if you see any of his
spiritual arrangements
in their original publication
there was always
in the inside front cover a
statement by Burleigh of how
to perform the spirituals,
with dignity and respect.
He didn't think that only
black people could sing them,
there was an interview of
Burleigh and his son Alston.
In which they talked about the fact
that some black singers don't
know how to sing spirituals
and there are white people
that sing them better.
The important thing is the
heart, the understanding
and presenting them with dignity.
Does that -- yes.
>> Thank you for the comment on
the Burleigh recording I was going
to ask something about that.
Maybe you said this, it is of
his arrangement of Go Down Moses.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Yes,
I didn't say that, thank you.
>> That's the one you
recorded, actually it's in a --
if any of you want to get a
CD of it, it can be purchased,
it's on a two CD set
called, Lost Sounds.
Issued by the Arceophone label
and that's how they got
the upload to YouTube.
My guess, he sounds stilted
I think he wanted to be sure
that the primitive of technology
picked all the pronunciation
of the word, so he
over did it a bit.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Yeah.
>> But at least it's something.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Thank you
and that of course is the recording
that accompanies Lost
Sounds by Tim Brooks.
>> It's based on the book, yes.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder:
And that's history
of recorded sound African-Americans.
>> So I had a few questions
I'll try and do them quickly,
that 1893 interview with Dvorak
you mentioned, he also referred
to Indian or Native American music
as being another possible source
for an American national music.
That didn't go quite as far as
African-American but I wondered
if by chance Burleigh ever
thought of that source.
The reason I ask that is at least
to my ears the song
Ethiopia Saluting the Colors,
sounds slightly Native
American as well.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: You're not
the first person that said that.
I worked through these
songs with James Sample
who was a retired conductor
and he didn't like that song,
Ethiopia Saluting the Colors and
he commented that those chords
at the beginning, that
was typical Indian music.
But yeah, Burleigh commented,
he was interviewed in 1911
when there was a performance
of the New World Symphony
about his relationship with
Dvorak and his influence.
And the influence
of African-American
music on Dvorak writing.
And he said you know, there was
a time when people understood
and recognized that I had worked
with Dvorak and had influenced him
but now people seemed
to have forgotten that.
But he did comment in that
interview and it's in the book.
He did comment about Dvorak's
interest in Native American music
and the influence that, that also
had on the New World Symphony.
>> Definitely.
Are there any extent
recordings or transcriptions
of those radio talks he gave?
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder:
That's what I don't know,
somebody needs to find that out.
>> And did he ever get to
meet Samuel Coleridge Taylor?
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Yes, he did,
in fact yeah that's
an interesting story.
He met him in London but he also and
Dvorak, when Coleridge Taylor came
to the United States
in 1904, 1906 and 1910,
he sang and he travelled with.
In fact he arranged the tour in
1906 which came to Pittsburg as well
as a number of other places.
Yeah, they were good friends
and there's interesting
correspondence between them.
In fact Coleridge Taylor called
Burleigh the greatest singer
of my songs.
>> Something I just wanted to throw
in that goes along with the question
about whether there
were any recordings.
Over the years my father obviously
had heard his grandfather sing
but had heard a lot of
other people sing his work.
And he said that Oral Moses
sounded more like his grandfather
than anyone else he'd ever heard.
So if you want to get a better
feel for what the old man sounded
like listen to some recordings
that Dr. Oral Moses did.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: It's called
Deep River, Songs and spirituals
by Harry T. Burleigh,
you got it, great.
Yes, it's published now,
it was originally issued
by Northeastern records
but it's been reissued
by Albany records and
it's easy to get.
I beg your pardon?
Oral Moses, O-r-a-l
Moses, the bass-baritone
from Kennesaw University
in Marietta, Georgia.
>> Thank you very much for
playing that beautiful recording
of My Lord What a Morning.
I actually had the opportunity
to participate in a performance
of that same arrangement in a series
of concerts last year
in New York City.
St. Bart's, Brooklyn
Cathedral, a few others.
We also did the Hall Johnson
arrangement of, When I was Sinking
Down and you're right
it's very challenging
with the acapella setting like that.
But my colleague Diane
Sayer conducted it
and ironically it was part
of a concert which was joined
with the Mozart Requiem on the
anniversary of September 11.
And it was a huge audience
and it was very emotional
but it was amazing
to see how starting
with that setting captured the
audience and in a colloquial,
in an English language of
beautiful classical piece
of music that Burleigh did.
And then brought them into this
performance of Mozart's Requiem.
So it was an amazing
experience, I wanted to mention
that as I said this choir
which performed that is going
to be participating in a performance
in Carnegie Hall this coming
June 29, which is going
to be a 100 birthday celebration
of Mrs. Silvia Olden Lee.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder:
And I'll be there.
>> Wonderful and it's
going to be joined,
this is the Schiller
Institute Choir, the Foundation
for the revival of classical culture
and the Harlem Opera Theater.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder:
That's wonderful.
>> And it's I think going to
include some of the performances
of Harry Burleigh's choral
settings and also some
of the solo settings
of the spirituals, so.
Thank you very much.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: That's
great, thank is so much.
Silvia Olden Lee if you
don't know was a coach
at the Metropolitan Opera
and she coached people
like Kathleen Battle
and lots of others.
Very important person and Adolphus
Hailstork has written a song called,
Who is Silvia?
It's great.
I wanted to say you can also find
a Mormon Tabernacle Choir recording
of this song but I love that
high school choir singing,
they do it so beautifully.
>> Nick Brown: There's time for
one more, if anyone got one, yes.
>> I just wondered about,
thank you, I just wondered
about Louise Burleigh because that's
a fascinating part of the story.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: It is a
fascinating part of the story,
Louise Alston Burleigh was
considerably younger than Burleigh
but they met, I'm not sure when
they met but Burleigh sang in D.C.,
she was born and raised in Brooklyn
which is now part of the Washington,
D.C. I think when they
married they hoped
to have a creative partnership,
but eventually I think the stage
wasn't big enough for both of them.
And first she wrote a lot of dialect
poetry which she was very successful
in doing readings of her poems.
But the marriage, they were
separated I think in 1913,
the marriage ended in 1915.
And she had discovered
another part of her heritage
which was Native American.
And she left New York city with
an Indian man named Albert,
his last name is escaping me.
She settled in the
Dells in Wisconsin
where she had a little cabin and
she became Princess Nadonis Shawa.
And she could get away with it
because she was a very
credible Indian princess.
But she couldn't allow anyone
to know that her husband
and her son were African-Americans
because she couldn't have owned
property and she was very successful
in [inaudible] programs
and [inaudible].
But her life was very separate
from her husband and her son.
That caused problems at his death
in claiming some of his estate.
That's another story,
it's told in the book.
Yeah, it's you know,
it's an American story,
her audiences didn't understand
enough about Native American culture
to know that what she was
presenting was her fiction.
And she was a very fine performer.
She commented in a letter to her
son that she would have liked
to be a vaudeville performer.
So you know, there ways diverged.
Yes, sure.
>> His mother was a
college graduate, right.
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: Yes, she
graduated from Avery College.
>> How did that influence
and inspire him to be able
to go forward [inaudible].
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: No question,
this was an abolitionist college
and it wasn't the first
college for African-Americans
but it was probably the first that
had an African-American faculty.
And it was a classical education,
she learned Greek and French
and Latin at her graduation she gave
as the Pittsburgh Newspaper
said, an essay in French.
And she was very good at
it, she also gave a speech
in which she adverted in terms
of sorrow to the many people
of her race who were still enslaved.
She was a very well educated woman
and the Erie papers, pick up,
the Pittsburgh story and said
oh, she's qualified to teach
in the best seminary in the land
but could she get a job teaching
at the Erie public school?
No, she could get a job as janitor.
But two of her daughters
became teachers
in the Erie public
school in the 1890's.
Burleigh's sister Eva was hired in
1890 and Burleigh's half-sister,
Bessie Elmendorf Marshall
taught music in the school
where her mother had been janitress.
So but she taught for a number
of years in the colored school
which was established partly
by her father, Hamilton Waters.
There were sometimes 300
students in that school,
so she was very gifted,
but frustrated.
>> Do you know if Burleigh
knew Emily Beech?
>> Dr. Jean E. Snyder: I don't
know if he knew her personally,
he sang some of her songs and
interesting when Dvorak made
that startling statement someone
interviewed European composers
and Boston composers of
whom Emily Beech was one,
she was one of the boys.
And she said well, I'm not a Native
American or an African-American I'm
from Scotch Irish ancestry.
And she wrote her Celtic symphony
as a direct kind of reflection
of Dvorak's New World Symphony, it
was in the same key but she quoted
and wrote in the style
of Celtic folksongs.
I don't know, it would be
really interesting to know
if they ever met personally,
I don't know that.
>> Nick Brown: Well, thank you all
so much for being here and thank you
to Dr. Snyder for sharing.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.